j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public consacré à un scandale qui dure
celui des féminicides depuis l'année
terrible de 2019 où 153 femmes avaient
été tuées par leurs compagnons ou
ex-compagnons ce bilan mortifère n'a
jamais vraiment baissé est-ce par manque
de volonté politique faut-il plus de
moyens plus d'argent que changerait
l'inscription du féminicide dans notre
code pénal avant de répondre à ces
questions le reportage de Fabien REER il
a rencontré Sandrine Bouchet dont la
sœur Guil a été tué par son
conjoint la vie de Sandrine Bouchet a
basculé un jour de septembre 2017 quand
sa petite sœur Guilen est assassinée par
son conjoint imolé par le feu en
présence de leur fille il y avait des
signes avantcoureurs mais ce qu'on
appelle les signaux faibles quand elle
me disait des certaines choses qu'il
allait la chercher tous les soirs à son
travail elle finissait à 21h je me suis
dit bah il est gentil il veut pas car
toute seule c'est dangereux elle m'a dit
elle a dénoncé des choses que moi je
prenais pour de la gentillesse de sa
part à lui or c'était du contrôle mais
j'étais pas formé et je m'en suis rendu
compte bien après au lendemain de la
mort de sa sœur Sandrine Bouchet fond
d'une association pour faire de la
prévention mais aussi pour accompagner
les familles touchées par un féminicide
qui ne bénéficie alors d'aucun
accompagnement spécifique aujourd'hui en
France les enfants de féminicide ils
sont laissés sur le bas côté de la route
il y a pas d'accompagnement
psychologique enfin rendez-vous compte
ma nièce elle a vu sa maman immolé sous
ses yeux on lui a proposé aucun
accompagnement psychologique un abandon
symptôme pour Sandrine du retard de
toute la société en matière de lutte
contre les féminicides en 2022 118
femmes ont été tuées par leur conjoint
ou leur ex en moyenne un féminicide
survient tous les 3 jours en France si
policiers et gendarmes se sont formés
pour mieux détecter les situations de
danger selon Sandrine c'est au niveau de
la justice que le bas blesse ce qu'on
explique aux familles c'est que ce ne
sont pas les policiers ni les gendarmes
qui classent les plaintes c'est les
magistrats c'est encore très compliqué
de
d'accéder au centre de formation pour
venir effectivement expliquer le
contrôle coertitif d'expliquer l'emprise
voilà quand nous on accompagne des
femmes et que la magistrate dit à la
victime et à l'agresseur bon maintenant
vous allez vous calmer et calmer du coup
sur un même pied d'égalité et la victime
et l'agresseur il y a quand même un
problème donc il faut effectivement que
la magistrature aussi se forme
l'association de Sandrine boucher milite
enfin pour sibiliser les jeunes et
appliquer la loi qui prévoit en théorie
depuis 2001 des cours sur l'égalité et
l'éducation affective et sexuelle à
l'école les féminicides en France retour
sur ce qu'on peut peut-être qualifier
d'échec collectif en tout cas c'est
l'une des questions que je poserai à mes
invités Laurence Rossignol bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice du valde
mararne vice-présidente de la délégation
au droits des femmes ici au Sénat Éric
corbeau bonsoir procureur général près
de la cour d'appel de PO
Emmanuel Daoud bonsoir vous êtes avocat
au war de Paris et co-président de
lawyers for women on est également en
duplexe avec Émilie Chandler qui est
député renaissance du valdoise coautrice
du plan rouge vif améliorer le
traitement judiciaire des violences
intra familial avec la sénatrice
Dominique Verrien bienvenue à vous et
Mathieu croissand évidemment est resté à
mes côtés je vais pour démarrer ouvrir
ce débat rappeler ce ce constat en 2022
de en France 118 femmes ont été tuées
par leur conjoint ou ex-conjoint on a
regardé on a remonté un peu les les les
années précédentes c'était 113 en 2021
102 en 2020 153 en 2019 123 en 2018 on
pourrait continuer Laurence Rossignol
pourquoi y a-t-il toujours enfin on n'y
arrive pas quoi pourquoi y y a-t-il
toujours autant de féminicide dans ce
pays échec collectif je je j'employais
ce terme tout à l'heure est-ce que vous
ouif pourquoi le patriarcat résiste
malgré maintenant presque une centaine
d'années de féminisme pourquoi la
violence des hommes continuent de
s'abattre sur les femmes et les enfants
pourquoi le le mode de de relation de de
certains hommes avec les femmes c'est un
instinct de c'est le développement de
leur instinct de propriété c'est
l'insupportabilité pour eux de la
liberté des femmes pourquoi les les les
cultures continue de banaliser les
violences continue de promou voir la
violence entre les femmes et les hommes
pourquoi la pornographie éduque nos
enfants à la sexualité donc vous nous
dites méange pas tout je pense qu' dans
viol que c'est un que finalement c'est
c'est une culture profondément ancré
dans nos sociétés estce qu'il a terrible
avec les violences faites aux femmes
c'est que c'est une culture qui est
ancrée dans de nombreuses sociétés sur
la planète et que s'il y a quelque chose
qui est assez universel dans la
condition des femmes qu'elle soit riche
qu'elle soit pauvre qu'elle soit dans un
pays développé dans un
pays moins développé ou qu'elle soit euh
elles sont toutes exposé de la même
façon aux violences sexuelles et au viol
à la violence des hommes euh et c'est
une nos civilisations sont bâtis sur les
la différenciation des sexes et la
hiérarchie des sexes nos civilisations
sont bâtis sur le fait que les hommes
sont supérieurs aux femmes ils en sont
les propriétaires et euh les femmes
lutte pour leur émancipation et que
cette lutte est une lutte violente parce
que dans chaque féminicide
euh chaque F on dit toujours il y a x
plus de 100 féminicid 120 mais chaque
féminicide est une histoire et
l'histoire d'une femme et c'est souvent
l'histoire d'une femme qui a voulu être
libre c'est ça qu'on a dans dans
nombreux féminicides les femmes qui ont
décidé de partir qu'elles supportaient
plus la C des violences pas tout il y a
pas toujours des violences préalables
par même pas des violences physiques
c'est pas forcément le coup de trop
c'est pas forment le coup de trop mais
ce qui est certain c'est qu'à momenté
les femmes ont dit je veux vivre libre
et que les hommes avec lesquels elles
vivent ne supportent pas cette liberté
et je finirai juste là-dessus en fait
tout toute cette tout tout ce contexte
toute cet écosystème de la violence il
se niche dans beaucoup de nos tolérances
quotidiennes à l'égard de la violence
envers les femmes euh d' cette
difficulté effectivement
à à trouver des solutions mais on va
voir que il y a quand même un travail
qui qui est fait et des solutions en
tout cas esquissé est-ce que vous parlez
d'un manque de moyens ou de volonté
politique Éric corbau alors vous avez
raison dans votre introduction de parler
de question collective comme vient de
dire Madame la la sénatrice euh
souvenons-vous il y a pas si longtemps
le meurtre de Nadine Trintignan toute la
presse titrée un drame de l'amour oui
crime passionnel crime passionnel
on é encore là il y a pas sis hein dans
cette sémantique le féminicide vous
l'utilisez dans le titre de votre
émission ça fait pas très longtemps
qu'on et même le comptage des
féminicides ça fait quelques années
seulement qu'on est donc il y a
effectivement une question systémique
sur les rapports vous a dit Nadine
tratignan c'est Marie tratigan Marie
tratigan pardon vous avez vous avez
compris il y a une question systémique
sur effectivement les relationss
hommes-femm et les violences au sein du
couple h et il faut travailler làdessus
et nous travaillons làdessus la volonté
politique vous l'avez rappelé le rapport
rougeevf euh de Madame Verrien et de
Madame chandel qui date de cette année a
été un révélateur hein de ce que l'on
pouvait faire de là où on devait aller
et comment on pouvait progresser on a
progressé dans les dernières années on a
progressé dans la formation des
policiers des gendarmes c'est pas
toujours pas parfait mais on l'a entendu
dans votre reportage mais il y a des
progrès immenses qui ont été fait des
moyens ont été donnés aussi à
l'institution judiciaire des moyens
humains hein dans le plan de de moyens
pour la justice une partie va être
consacrée aussi à ce sujet et PU et
pourtant il y a pas il y a pas une
baisse majeure je je je suis pasnilé par
le le nombre mais quand même on reste on
reste à des qui sont peu près les mê on
a progressé avec le bracelet
antiapprochement qui date de de
maintenant 4 ans voilà on a des outils
qui avancent il faut qu'on continue faut
pas s'exonérer j'exonère rien je dis
juste qu'il faut continuer à progresser
la progression aller sur la formation ça
a été dit dans le reportage mais c'est
vrai formation des magistrats formation
des enquêteurs sur les signaux faibles
on y reviendra évidemment et ça c'est
important ouais euh je je sur sur ces
118 femmes qui sont mortes sous les
coups de leurs compagnons ou
ex-compagnons alors effectivement il y a
autant de cas et et de DRAM mais c'est
intéressant de voir effectivement celle
qui avaiit alerté ou pas com comment ça
s'était passé avant 37 avaient déjà subi
des violences 24 les avait signalé aux
forces de l'ordre 19 avaient déposé
plainte et trois faisaient l'objet d'un
dispositif de protection Emmanuel Daoud
les les dans certains cas les
signalements les plaintes n'ont pas
suffi pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a une
faille et si oui où écoutez je vais pas
commenter des dossier que je ne connais
pas il y a non mais sur le le contexte
général le contexte général il y a un
effort de formation les les policiers
les gendarmes sont de mieux en mieux
formés par exemple les les les femmes
victimes sont accueillliis
préférentiellement par des des agents de
police ou des gendarmes femmes c'est
important aussi d'avoir cette cette
orientation on peut se sentir plus en
confiance il y a des dysfonctionnements
ces dysfonctionnements donneent parfois
lieu à des à des sanctions
disciplinaires mais je vrais quand même
pas généraliser en disant que que que
que tout va mal euh sil y a eu des
progrès considérables on les a et on les
a constaté nous praticiens du droit je
parle des des avocats et des avocats oui
et C effort de formation il doit aussi
porter sur par exemple la profession de
d'avocat parce que lorsque nous
accueillons des des femmes qui se disent
victimes de de violence il faut aussi
que nous soyons en mesure nous de
détecter les les les signaux faible
l'urgence qui doit s'imposer le fait
d'alerter immédiatement le parquet ou
pas alors il y a eu des
dysfonctionnements la police ou la
justice s'en est s'en est chargé pour
certaines procédures et j'ai pas
d'explication qui soit une explication
mécanique et et générale mais il faut
voir aussi la pression qui s'exerce sur
nos policiers sur nos gendarmes le le
stress que cela peut générer le manque
de moyens la culture du chiffre et
parfois il y a eu des des des
professionnels de la police ou de la
gendarmerie qui n'ont pas suffisamment
écouté c'est une c'est une réalité mais
encore une fois je je ne peux pas je ne
peux pas généraliser Émilie Chandler le
le l'une de des des 118 victimes de de
de cette année 202 de disposait d'un
téléphone grand danger pour deux autres
le conjoint ou l'ex-conjoint faisait
l'objet d'un d'un contrôle du judiciaire
évidemment c'est ces systèmes mis en
place et heureusement ont fonctionné
pour beaucoup d'autres femmes mais
parfois ça ne suffit pas comment vous
l'expliquez ça alors déjà ce que je
voudrais rappeler c'est qu'il y a encore
quelques années on parlait pas de
féminicide on parlait de crime
passionnel donc le compage n'était pas
bon on ne savait pas compter les femmes
victimes de féminicide aujourd'hui on on
on avance on progresse on progresse en
marchant finalement on parle de
féminicide on a déplacé un petit peu le
le curseur dans l'analyse des chiffres
on parle finalement aussi de foyer on
parle de continuum de violence on parle
de contrôle coercitif on parle de
formation on parle finalement des
nouveaux outils mis à disposition des
professionnels alors nous ce qu'on veut
éviter c'est un trou dans la raquette on
est bien d'accord qu'un téléphone grave
danger ça doit fonctionner un bracelet
antiprapprochement ça doit fonctionner
on voudrait que ça fonctionne de manière
absolue on travaille à améliorer les
dispositifs en continu néanmoins
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que de
temps en temps ça ripe encore un peu et
ce qu'il faut c'est que tout le monde
travaille dans le même sens il y a des
moyens qui sont donnés il y a on en fait
une politique une politique une
politique publique mais pour ça il faut
continuer et ne pas lâcher pour toujours
finalement travailler à ce que la
violence sorte des foyers la violence
sorte de la société parce que comme le
disait Laurence Rossignol tout à l'heure
la difficulté c'est que la violence
envers les femmes elle est partout et en
continu donc comment on fait pour lutter
contre ça bah on se mobilise tous et on
continue à travailler les sujets le plan
Rif fait des recommandations des
préconisations vous avez les pôles qui
seront effectifs à comptter du 1er
janvier il y aura aussi une proposition
de loi sur l'ordonnance de protection
d'urgence qui devrait être analysé il
faut continuer continuer continuer pour
donner les meilleurs outils viendra
là-dessus évidemment les PA spécialisé
ordonnance de protection un certain
nombre de mesures qui sont déjà mis en
œuvre ou qui sont dans les dans les
tuyaux si j'ose dire je vous propose
dans ce débat de s'appuyer sur plusieurs
témoignages je vous et on va écouter
tout de suite Lucien dub c'est le le
papa de Julie elle a été tué par son
ancien compagnon écout je connais mais
encore une fois le problème de ces 100
et quelques victimes qui sont partis
cette année c'est qu'on est toujours
dans le même principe c'est qu' elles
ont le courage de porter plainte que
quand elles sortent du commissariat de
police elles sont seules c'est cet
accompagnement qui qui est important
parce que pour moi je dis bien parce que
quand elles ressortent d'un commissariat
ell savent pas où aller soit elle
retourne à la maison et c'est c'est
l'enfer soit elle se retrouve à la rue
donc je pense que il y a eu beaucoup de
choses de fait je le reconnais mais pour
moi la chose principale c'est de pas les
laisser sortir seul des commissariats de
police Laurence signal on est dans dans
le cas d'un féminicide post séparation
c'estd que elle a Julie elle avait
quitté cet homme qui est aussi le père
de ses enfants et qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire là comment on peut mieux
accompagner ces femmes qui qui ont le
courage de porter plainte le le son papa
dit quand ell sort du commissariat elles
sont seules oui et déjà ça déjà ça
sous-entend qu'au commissariat ce
qu'elles avaient à dire a été entendu et
pris en compte en fait sur la question
des f enfin sur les féminicides on est
dans une on progresse énormément dans la
connaissance faut quand même pas pas
oublier qu'il y a 10 ans
10 12 ans ça n'intéressait personne
c'était des faits divers les féminicides
et puis une espèce de fatalité voilà ça
ça fait partie de du risque d'être une
femme voilà il y a une fatalité les
femmes peuvent être tuées par leur
conjoint qui les aiment trop et qui les
aiment tellement qu'il les tu donc on
avance dans la compréhension de ce qui
un féminicide et effectivement dans les
violences postséparation les féminicide
on a encore beaucoup à travailler je
crois sur parce que c'est un élément
important et tout tout est lié le les la
question des enfants de la garde des
enfants les pressions qui sont faites
sur la mer les infanticide parce qu'il
une autre façon de tuer une femme c'est
de tuer ses enfants voilà c'est sa mort
c'est sa mort psychologique et affective
je dis ça parce qu'il y a encore peu de
temps il y a eu un triple infanticide
terrible dans mon département dans le
valde Marne qui était qui a eu lieu post
séparation et les enfants était en
partagé entre le papa et la maman de
manière non non judiciarisée h c'est un
arrangement conventionnel entre eux mais
cette dame était allée deux fois
signaler au commissariat que ça se
passait mal au moment du passage de bras
au moment de la remise des enfants deux
fois au commissariat signaler ça alors
elle av pas déposé de plainte elle avait
juste fait une main courante normalement
ça devrait être un point d'alerte
essentiel ce sont les signaux faies dont
on ce sont les signaux faies parce que
les enfants sont l'objet des
transactions toxiques qui se font sur
les maire donc on on comprend mieux le
film absolument formidable qui est
jusqu'à la garde où dans la première
scène une femme tout tout en elle
exprime la peur et la la jaff qui est en
face d'elle ne juge la jugeal pardon qui
est en face d'elle ne comprend pas ce
que cette femme dit avec son langage
corporel et puis on a encore dans la
justice dans la justice civile beaucoup
trop une culture qui est beaucoup trop
une culture de du maintien du lien avec
le
euh de la suspicion j' une chose qui est
importante c'est la suspicion sur la
parole des femmes euh les les femmes ça
existe encore mais bien entendu bien
entendu moi j'ai des je suis je ne
connais que les dossiers qui se passent
mal les cas douloureux les quand quand
des choses se passent bien les gens
viennent pas me voir mais j'ai beaucoup
de dossiers dans lesquels les femmes
elles vont pas elles font elles sont pas
l'objet d'un féminicide celles-ci mais
elles sont l'objet de ces fameuses
violences post séparation et dans lequel
les les Pères poursuivre les femmes pour
délit de non représentation
d'enfants où les enfants sont le moyen
de continuer d'exercer la violence sur
sur la mère hors de tout cela sur tout
cela on a encore beaucoup à apprendre et
à former les magistrats ouais votre avis
là-dessus le délit de suspicion ou cette
façon de ne pas croire les femmes est-ce
que vous vous le ressentez est-ce que
vos clientes vous vous l'ont exprimé ça
plusieurs fois bien sûr de toute façon
quand de quand un homme et une femme
s'affrontte dans dans dans une enceinte
judiciaire parce que c'est la traduction
bah de violences qui peuvent se dérouler
dans dans dans le couple ou post post
séparation c'est la parole de l'un
contre la parole de l'autre et dans la
dialectique judiciaire euh on va mettre
en mettre en cause la parole de de la
femme et moi ce qui m'a paraarît très
important c'est ce que vous disiez
madame c'est que il y a un continuum des
violences qui sont exercées sur les
femmes au travers des enfants et au
travers de la fixation de la résidence
et de l'hébergement ou plus exactement
des modalités de droit de visite ou pas
du père et euh je je le dis sans sans
sans esprit de polémique il y a une
difficulté me semble-t-il que ça soit du
côté des juges des enfants comme des
juges aux affaires familiales
d'appréhender la globalité de ces de ces
violences et de toujours tenter enfin ou
de tenter parfois je vais essayer de
d'être plus plus nuancé de préserver
comme si c'était un mantra le lien entre
le père et les enfants sans se rendre
compte qu'il y a une situation de de
violence qui peut dégénérer évidemment
sur les enfants et parmi les
statistiques que vous avez cité sur ces
118 féminicide il y a 12 enfants qui ont
été tués donc on voit bien que que que c
ces dossiers dramatiques concernent
aussi les enfants je vais vous donner la
parole parce que évidemment ça vous
faire réagir mais je voudrais retourner
vers vers Émilie Chandler parce que vous
aviez déposé je crois que c'était il y a
il y a un an une proposition de loi vous
vous y avez fait allusion tout à l'heure
pour allonger la durée de l'ordonnance
de protection alors là ça pourrait être
utile j'imagine dans le cas de voilà de
de violence post séparation
expliquez-nous FO alors en fait c'est
c'est prévoir une ordonnance une
ordonnance de l'urgence dans
l'ordonnance de protection des 6 jours
c'est-à-dire une ordonnance qui qui
pourrait être pris sous 24 heures par un
magistrat pour qui serait une ordonnance
accessoire à l'ordonnance de 6 jours
mais qui permettrait vraiment au
magistrat de prendre les mesures
immédiates pour permettre à la femme de
partir dans les meilleures conditions ou
de rester dans les Meille meilleur
conditions pour justement trancher les
sujets de des enfants de de du domicile
vraiment en urgence parce que la femme
ne doit pas avoir peur la femme ne doit
pas avoir peur de sortir du commissariat
après avoir déposé plainte elle ne doit
pas être seule nous avons mis en place
le pack nouveau départ pour qu'elle
puisse être accompagnée mais cette femme
doit pouvoir être libre de partir une
femme par définitivement au bout de se
tentative de départ en France c'est
c'est grave de se de dire ça il faut la
rassurer et dire à toutes les femmes
qu'elles peuvent partir qu'elles peuvent
quitter la violence qu'elles doivent
quitter la violence pour se protéger
pour protéger leurs enfants et que la
justice doit les protéger Éric Corbon et
ça repose la question vous l'évoquez à
l'instant de la la première réponse qui
peut être parfois policière qui peut
être ensuite judiciaire si effectivement
l'objectif c'est de maintenir à tout
pris le lien père enfant bon vous avez
raison première chose il faut former les
magistrats h les fonctionnaires de
police les gendarmes mais aussi les
magistrats ça se met en place l'École
nationale de la magistrature va offrir à
partir de cette année une formation
spécifiques sur les concepts qui sont à
l'œeuvre l'emprise le contrôle coercitif
qu'est-ce que c'est pour que les
magistrats le connaissent et les pôles
vif qui vont permettre aussi donc ça son
spécialisés c'est ça c'està-d qu'au sein
des juridictions on va spécialiser des
magistrats sur ces questions aussi bien
des juges civils que des juges pénaux
c'està-dire aussi bien des jugesx
affaires familiales des juges des
enfants des juges correctionnels qui
jugent correctionnel les VI
pour que tout ce monde là tous ces
collègues sortent de leur couloir de
nage et que l'on nit pas les difficultés
qu'on évoqué avec ses notions oui certes
il est violent vis-à-vis de sa femme
mais mais finalement c'est peut-être un
bon papa on va lui laisser les enfants
et avec le passage de bras que que que
qu'on vient de d'exploser et et les
limites que ça que ça comporte donc
voilà je vous donne un exemple à la cour
d'appel de Poitier ce que nous allons
mettre en place à compté du 1er janvier
c'est que nous allons juger dans le même
temps à la même audience par les mêmes
juges les affaires civiles c'est-à-dire
le divorce qui se passe mal et l'affaire
pénale oui il a il a tapé sa femme et
c'est les mêmes juges qui vont juger la
personne en même temps à la même
audience voilà pour que on sorte de
cette de cette difficulté avec des
mesures de
protection mesures de protection
l'ordonnance de protection le téléphone
grave danger le bracelet an
rapprochement sont toujours des outils
qu'il faut continuer à développer et une
notion qu'il faut qu'on développer aussi
je je termine là-dessus ça a été équé
tout à l'heure c'est le contrôle
coercitif on y reviendra un peu plus
tard si vous voulez parce que moi c'est
une notion j'avoue je ne connaissais pas
ces ces termes et donc je pense que ce
seraéress expliquera ce que c'est dans
dans un instant mais je voudrais vous
entendre Laurence rossinel je voudrais
vous entendre sur cette cette idée
prolonger l'ordonnance de protection
alors à ma connaissance c'est pas encore
dans dans la loi pourquoi ça coince
estce que
alors depuis 10 ans on a progressé dans
la prise en charge des féminicides et
des violences intrafamiliales plus
généralement pour autant il y a des
problèmes de méthodes comment on a
légiféré au cours des des 5 si dernières
années par proposition loi par petit
bout d'abord je trouve ça très
déstabilisant pour les magistrats que la
loi change continuellement sans jamais
être inscrite dans un grand cadre moi
j'attends depuis plusieurs années depuis
en fait depuis le Grenel depuis Mitou à
partir de 2017 on a une une poussée de
de ilisation je rappelle quand même que
tout cela est dû essentiellement au
militants de féministes hein qui a
commencé le compage c'est pas les
pouvoirs publics ce sont des militants
de féministes avec des compes qui a
commencé à dénoncer la manière dont on
qualifiait les féminicides en crime
passionnel ce sont les militant féminist
dit il y a pas de réponse globale ce que
je dire c'est que tout ce qui se passe
là c'est quand même essentiellement sous
l'impulsion des associations et des
militantes féministes alors les pouvoirs
publics effectivement prennent le relais
et essayent de traduire en politique
publique ce que les les ONG enfin les
militantes dénoncent et et demandent
mais on aurait dû avoir depuis le Grenel
une loi cadre une grande loi cadre qui
traiterait l'ensemble des problèmes or
on on bidouille parce que je peux pas le
dire autrement on bidouille avec des PPL
moi je dépose des amendements
systématiquement entre autres puisque
vous parlez dans dans protection pour
que son sa durée soit allongée voilà
qu'on passe à un an et puis si et puis
on verra s'il faut si les choses
s'arrangent mais qu'on passe à un an je
me fais systématiquement refuser mes
amendements et puis parfois je les vois
arriver 3 mois après 4 mois après dans
une autre proposition de la proposition
de c'est devenue le moyen de légiférer
sur les violences faites aux femmes non
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire nous
faut tout oui on va continuer en parler
Mathieu je me tourne vers vous avec
cette question est-ce queil y il y a
derrière ce ce nombre de féminicid une
une faillite des pouvoirs publics un
échec politique et quand on constate le
nombre de meurtres on peut répondre que
oui pour le dire autrement en terme
d'obligation de résultat c'està-dire
l'attente légitime de la population des
associations
pour que ce type de tragédie ne se
reproduise plus ben la réponse est oui
les résultats ne sont pas là si on
raisonne en terme d'obligation de moyens
c'estàd la somme des décisions des
mesures qui que donnent les pouvoirs
publics à la société pour combattre ce
fléo là pour le coup la réponse mérite
d'être nuancé parce qu'on a commencé à
le dire depuis le début de de ce débat
beaucoup de choses ont été faites depuis
10 ans et pour ainsi dire jamais autant
de choses n'avaient été faites dans ce
pays sur la question des violences
faites aux femmes en général et et des
féminicides on doit enêre au 7e plan
interministériel de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes il y a eu
lors du précédent quinquena vous l'avez
rappelé laurenceigol quatre ou cinq lois
de mémoire qui traitait de cette
question alors par des B des tourné
c'est vrai qu'il jamais eu de grandes
lois cadres de grandes lois de grands
projets de loi uniquement dédiés à cette
à cette question là il y a eu un Grenel
vous l'avez rappelé en 2019 ça a été la
grande cause du premier quinquenmanuel
Macron et c'est encore la grande cause
du quinqua il y a des mesures qui ont
été prises je le disais des circulaires
qui ont été publiées vous l'avez rappelé
des personnels qui ont été form mais il
y a des policiers des gendarmes
maintenant des magistrats des outils qui
ont été mis en place vous l'avez dit le
téléphone grave danger le bracelet
antiapprochement dans la police des
équipes spécialisées ont été lancées
dans la justice des pôles spécialisés
vous l'avez dit ont été aussi créé des
places d'hébergement ont été créées
aussi pour pour les femmes en danger on
peut donc on ne peut pas dire que rien
n'a été fait alors qu'est-ce qui ne
fonctionne pas bah il y a sans doute
plusieurs aspects euh enfin pour
plusieurs aspects quand on écoute les
associations il y a des questions de
moyens financiers celain plusieurs
associations souignent qu'entre
l'intention et les acte il y a parfois
encore un faussé on l'a vu dans le
reportage tout à l'heure je dirais que
tout n'est pas encore en place et tout
n'est pas encore à sa place il faut sans
doute aussi combler des failles donner
une peut-être donner une existence
juridique au terme féminicide on va en
parler je ne sais pas ce que ça
compenserait ou non sans doute mieux
documenté poursuivre la connaissance du
phénomène une réalité statistique mais
ce qu'il faut surtout en fait c'est un
changement de paradigme c'est-à-dire que
ces crimes que tout le monde condamne
deviennent réellement aux yeux de nos
élus insupportablebles et que ce soit
érigé en priorité absolue et là pour le
coup on n est pas et puis il y a aussi
peut-être ne pas tout attendre des élus
mais ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure il y
a un sursaut attente de la société parce
que là encore il y a un paradoxe on en a
jamais autant parlé des féminicides il y
a jamais eu autant de livres de films
d'émissions sur le sujet mais ça ne
suffit pas encore à ce que le corps
social dans son ensemble fasse de ce
crime un tabou insurmontable or là c'est
encore un plus long travail que de
changer évidemment que de faire changer
les mentalités euh Éric Corbo est-ce que
c'est est-ce que ça commence par
l'éducation des enfants des parents
vis-à-vis de leurs enfants évidemment
mais aussi à l'école oui alors je suis
pas en charge de l'éducation non mais je
pense qu'en tant que citoyen vous avez
votre avis
raison c'est c'est une affaire on l' on
l'a expliqué ça arrive au moment d'une
souvent les féminicides arrivent au
moment de la séparation une séparation
dans un couple les deux partis souffrent
c'est affreux votre conjoint ou votre
épouse décide de vous quitter les deux
souffrre le problème c'est que ce sont
seulement les hommes qui tuent la femme
c'est jamais la femme qui tue l'homme or
elle souffre elle aussi de la sparation
on imagine bien une séparation pourquoi
est-ce que c'est toujours l'homme qui
tue la femme et jamais le contraire
c'est donc bien qu'il y a un problème
d'éducation à la à
l'égalité de virilité je dire exacerbé
qui fait que de possession de la femme
par l'homme qui fait qu'il que l'homme
n'accepte pas que sa femme à un moment
donné décide de reprendre sa liberté
parce que il est audieux ou parce qu'il
exerce ce contrôle dont je parlais tout
à l'heure donc voilà le problème il est
là laence rignol tout àhe j'ai j'ai
évoqué le travaille des associations des
militants féministes je dois ajouter que
il y a des militants de la lutte contre
les féminicides qui sont pas tous dans
des des actions féministes mais je en
écoutant procureur corbeau avec sa binô
Genola jolie Cuse on a maintenant des
magistrats qui sont investis SP enfin
qui qui sont devenus des militants la
lutte contre les féminicides il y a des
policiers on a des on a des des brigades
de gendarmerie donc on voit bien quand
même que la il y a une mobilisation dans
la société civile euh qui qui est quand
même supérieure et qui qui est
importante euh pour autant je pense que
la lutte contre les féminicides ce n'est
pas que de la polique de la politique
police justice elle suppose que
l'ensemble des politiques publiques
ailleent bien parce que le problème
qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est que la justice
va pas très bien globalement voilà il y
a des des dossiers sans TASS la justice
est en souffrance les services sociaux
la protection de l'enfance ne va pas
bien donc il y a pas le travail de
prévention d'accompagnement des familles
et de repérage qui est fait le l'école
on a des problèmes aussi en fait c'est
et j'ajouterai deux choses le logement
c'està-dire que c'est bien joli on dit
aux femmes partez encore faut-il
qu'elles a un logement et là on
construit plus de logement social on a
une crise du logement ça impacte aussi
la possibilité des femmes de de de de
s'extraire de la de la violence donc en
fait on dit oui on fait beaucoup depuis
des années mais on ne peut pas avancer
avoir des résultats lorsque l'ensemble
des politiques publiques c'est effondre
autour de celle de lutte contre les
féminicides et puis les gens vont pas
bien voilàand même le dire aussi il y a
des familles qui dysfonctionne on a
également et enfin j'ajouterai une
dernière chose pour montrer la cohérence
quand on prend le sujet de l'alcool
50 % des féminicides impliquent une
alcoolisation soit de l'auteur soit de
la victime et parfois des deux quand on
demande au Président de la République de
faire des campagnes contre l'alcoolisme
quand aujourd'hui vous avez avz 200
médecins alcologues qui demandent que on
fasse une campagne pour le janvier sec
le drery c'està dire qu'on va pas et ben
qu'est-ce qu'on de quoi on s'aperçoit on
s'aperçoit que les lobby alcooliers ceux
qui sont pour la promotion de la cons de
la vente et de la production de la vente
et de la consommation d'alcool sont plus
forts que nous qui disons attention
l'alcool est un facteur des féminicides
donc je cent qu'on attire l'attention
làdessus parce que depuis 10 ans qu'on
parle féminicide justice police je
voudrais qu'on attire l'attention le
fait que c'est l'ensemble des politiques
publiques qui doivent être app en
soutien à la lutte contre les
féminicides sinon on n'y arrivera pas si
tout s'écroule autour de celle-là alors
je vous propose d'écouter puisque vous
vous nous dites on a un manque
finalement de de réactivité ou de
réponse politique ou de volonté
politique de la part de d'Emmanuel
Macron non non mais j'ai j'ai bien
entendu il y a par vous donnerz un
exemple qui est le le l'alcoolisme en
disant on n pas vraiment de de réponse
et de grand plan bon très bien logement
et l'alcool oui oui et alors je vous
propose parce que c'est sur un point
précis d'écouter justement une prise de
position de du du président de la
républque on est en 2019 il est est à la
tribune de l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU
il l'emploie ce terme de féminicide et
et il pose la question du d'un statut
juridique écoutons-le les féminicides
continuent en France comme dans tant
d'autres États nous devons donner un
statut juridique à ce sujet et bâtir une
action efficace pour l'éradiquer encore
davantage que nous ne l'avons fait 2019
c'est c'est la pire année 153 féminicide
censé en France ilyie schundler donner
un statut juridique au féminicide ça
n'est toujours pas fait
pourquoi alors ça n'est pas fait parce
que il y a il y a d'une part il faudrait
changer un texte et effectivement lancer
encore un nouveau texte et je ne sais
pas si ça si ce texte là est dans les
tuyux ou pas parce que moi j'ai quand
même un enjeu c'est de dire que les
violences intrafamiliales et la lutte
contre les féminicides c'est quelque
chose de transpartisan je ne suis pas du
tout favorable à en faire un outil
politique de de prise de parole je crois
qu'on doit tous se mobiliser en essayant
d'avancer tous ensemble parce que par
exemple sur les associations on a
effectivement tissu associatif qui a une
particularité française qui fait un
travail absolument formidable le
gouvernement a changé les textes pour
que les associations puissent avoir des
budgets annuels avec de la visibilité
sur sur plusieurs années c'est-à-dire
que elles vont pouvoir engager des
travaux en ayant de la visibilité sur 3
ans en termees budgétairees ça c'est une
nouveauté générale pour les associations
qui va forcément impacter les
associations qui luttent contre les
féminicides et ça c'est c'est une
politique publique mais il y a aussi un
point que moi j'entends pas très souvent
et qui ne fait pas plaisir à tout le
monde c'est aussi mettre des moyens pour
les les victimes évidemment mais traiter
aussi les auteurs pour éviter la
récidive parce que combien vous avez
d'auteurs auteur de violence conjugale
de violence intrafamiliale qui tape ses
gosses qui tape sa femme qui qui se
sépare qui va faire de la détention ou
pas et qui va recommencer avec une autre
parce qu'on aura jamais traité le
problème il y a les addictions d'une
part et puis il y a une prise en charge
psychologique des victimes et et traiter
le sujet de la récidive euh alors je je
voudrais il y a un autre thème dont on
va parler c'est cette ce contrôle COTIF
dont dont vous parliez je pense que
c'est important mais quand même sur
cette question de d'inscrire le
féminicide dans dans notre code pénal je
voudrais vous entendre l'un et l'autre
là-dessus est-ce que c'est est-ce qu'il
faut le faire est-ce que pour vous ce
serait un
progrès euh si ça permet d'identifier
euh ces homicides qui sont commis par
des hommes sur des femmes qu'il
considèrent comme leur propriété et
faire que ça soit une prise de
conscience collective plus évidente
parce que on l'aura mis sur l'hôtel de
la loi et qu'on aura dit il faut
l'identifier comme tel il faut le faire
je rappelle quand même que nous avons un
code pénal qui prévoit que le meurtre
c'est 30 ans de de réclusion criminelle
et que lorsqu'il y a la circonstance
aggravante c'est écrit dans la loi de
meurtre commis par un conjoint ou un
concubin ou un ex-conjoint ou un
exccubin c'est la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité donc ce sont des sanctions
pénales qui a priori sont dissuasives et
on voit que ça n'empêche pas d'endiguer
ce flot récurrent de de malheureusement
plus d'une centaine de de de victimes de
féminicide chaque année donc si ça
permet de d'un choc des consciences euh
pourquoi pas mais je ne suis pas sûr que
cette modification soit à elle seule
suffisante je vous pose la même question
je partage l' viis qui vient d'être
exprimé c'est pas le plus importantire
féminicide dans notre important mais
qu'on nose utiliser cette sémantique et
vous le faites ce soir le titre de cette
émission c'est les féminicides il y a 5
ans lorsque nous utilisions ce terme on
levait les sourcils quand même en disant
mais mais comment donc maintenant la
sémantique est forte elle est présente
et on en on l'utilise la symbolique
serait également forte de la traduire
dans le code pénal elle n'est pas
nécessaire pour travailler sur ce sujet
mais je crois que ce serait une
symbolique forte pas pas nécessaire mais
une symbolique forte en tout cas ce mot
il faut continuer à l'utiliser vous nous
avez parlé des des signaux faibles piste
d'amélioration objectif pour les
policiers les gendarmes les les les
magistrats c'est ce que nous dit
justement cette policière qui est
référente violence int familiale dans le
département des ivelines on l'écoute
prend toutes les plaintes il y a a on n
pas le droit de refuser une plainte je
j'espère que ça n'arrive plus mais je
suis consciente que malheureusement ça
peut encore arriver mais ça il faut que
ce soit signalé on prend toutes les
plaintes et après a ce qu'on leur fait
comprendre aux collègues c'est
aujourd'hui on travaille beaucoup sur la
notion d'emprise de contrôle coercitif
et de comment on pourrait dire de de de
tout ce qui se passe avant un féminicide
pour que justement on n'arrive pas à ce
féminicide tout tous les petits signaux
faibles qui pourraient nous dire on a
par exemple le questionnaire
d'évaluation du danger ou là c'est pas
quelque chose qui doit être rempli sur
un bout table en 2 minutes il faut
vraiment prendre conscience de tout ce
que nous dit la victime et c'est tous
ces signaux faibles voire signaux forts
additionnés qui vont nous faire dire
attention là il y a vraiment danger quoi
il y a risque de passage à l' et
Emmanuel Daoud c'est quoi le contrôle
coerif c'est une forme d'emprise en fait
oui c'est une forme c'est une forme
d'emprise qui va de qui va de je je
porte un contrôle sur la façon dont dont
dont ma femme est vêue euh de de
contrôler ses de contrôler ses sorties
de ne pas laisser de ne pas la laisser
s'exprimer en en public enfin c'est tout
ces petites contraintes et
soumissions au quotidien qui font que
pardon l'isoler l'isoler la coupé de ses
amis et faire en sorte qu'ell soit il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont ma propriété qu'elle ne sorte pas
de chez moi sauf si je l'accompagne ou
sauf si je la laiss sortir mais il y a
de d'éminents spécialistes autour de la
table puis c'estur témoignage là-dessus
en préparant l'émission C'est par
exemple une femme qui qui avait
l'interdiction de mettre du du vernis en
dehors de chez elle c'estàd et qui
panique un jour avec une collègue en dis
j'ai j'ai du vernis faut que tu me le
retires avant que je rentre chez moi
enfin voilà c'est un exemple il y en a
évidemment des des des milliers d'autres
mais si vous permettez dans notre
entourage on a pu rencontrer des des
femmes libres indépendantes qui vivaient
leur vie de femme comme elle
l'entendaient et heureusement et qui euh
après s'être paxé mis en concubinage ou
marié changeait totalement de de de
façon d'être et s'éteignait
littéralement et c'est bien les
entourages qui doivent agir ce sont bien
celles et ceux qui les entourent qui
disent attention mais je je veux pas
être dans le rôle de Yaka faucon c'est
complexe mais on voit bien ça on l'a
tous vu dans nos dans dans nos
entourages mais c'est c'est intéressant
par moi j'avoueblement je connaissais
pas ce terme je le redis et et et je
pense queon est face à un échec
collectif et donc face à une
responsabilité face au signneau faible
qui peut être une responsabilité
collective je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez il y a il y a quelques jours on a
fêté les 75 ans de la la Charte
européenne des droits de l'homme h le
contrôle coercitif c'est la privation
des droits humains derrière la porte de
l'appartement à l'intérieur de
l'appartement au sein du couple c'est
l'homme qui prive sa conjointe ou sa'ac
compagne de ses droits humains de voir
qui elle veut de s'habiller comme elle
veut de se déplacer comme elle veut nous
avons à à Poitier étudieré 80 dossiers
de féminicide 20 ans de féminicide sur
notre ressort ouais dans avec la docteur
delbre qui est une médecin légiste
engagée sur ce sujet on a travaillé
là-dessus avec Madame jolicose la
première présidente dans tous les cas il
y avait du contrôle coercitif avant le
passage à l'acte c'est-à-dire tous ces
éléments qui viennent d'être évoqués de
contrôle et de maîtrise de la personne
de l'autre du couple et et a plusieurs
législations en Europe en Écosse par
exemple la Belgique s'y intéresse on
fait passer une incrimination il y a une
incrimination dans le code pénal qui
s'appelle le contrôle coercitif je crois
que là il y a une marche à gravir pour
peut-être arriver à une définition
légale et qui permettrait d'englober
beaucoup plus de situations et peut-être
aussi d'avoir un côté beaucoup plus
prédictif et préventif de ces situations
de fémin donne la parole tout de suite
je me tourne versie Chandler sur ce
cette idée le contrôle coercitif est-ce
que voilà comment le le détecter est-ce
qu'on a les outils juridique vous nous
dites que pour l'instant on les a pas
vraiment pour finalement se servir de
d'un fait de de contrôle coeritif pour
bah empêcher une dérive vers la violence
alors on a la chance aujourd'hui d'avoir
des chercheurs et des chercheus qui font
un travail incroyable vous avez cité
Genola jolicose il y a aussi Andrea
vintila qui travaille sur le contrôle
tif qui nous permet de mieux appréhender
les contours parce qu'en fait le
contrôle coercitif c'est juste avant
l'emprise donc c'est vraiment les
premiers signaux alors c'est quelque
chose de très difficile à détecter il
faut évidemment que policiers gendarmes
soi formés donc dans les grilles
d'évaluation du danger du ministère de
l'Intérieur maintenant de manière
généralisée vous avez les critères du
contrôle coercitif pour que lors de la
première plainte ou main courante ça
puisse être détecté très tôt mais avant
ça je pense qu'il faut aussi faire de la
sensibilisation au sein des les
entreprises parce que cette femme qui
est isolée souvent elle a encore un
travail et on se rend compte en parlant
avec les entreprises avec les référents
vif des grandes entreprises que il faut
qu'il y ait aussi des détecteurs
possibles qui peuvent relever ces
signaux faibles pour les signaler et
pour aider à la détection parce que
c'est uniquement si on détecte
suffisamment tôt qu'on va pouvoir éviter
les drames donc vraiment moi je je pense
qu'il faut travailler ce cette notion de
contrôle coercitif en parler de plus en
plus et voir comment on peut donner les
meilleurs outils au au professionnels
qui ont à traiter les dossiers Laurence
Rossignol oui mais en fait je trouve pas
ça si difficile que ça en fait il y a
deux approches il y enfin il y a deux
angles de vue il y a l'angle de vue
judiciaire c'està dire comment dans la
justice on va utiliser le contrôle
coritif et puis il y a ce qui nous
implique chacun de nous en tant qu'être
humain citoyen au quotidien combien de
fois ça nous est arrivé aux uns ou aux
autres de sortir d'un dîner et de se
dire j'aime pas la manière dont ce MeCl
parle à sa femme j'aime pas la il y a
quelque chose qui me gêne terriblement
et ben là quand on vous sortez quand
vous sortez d'un dîner que vous dites ça
vous pouvez être à peu près sûr que vous
Z en face de vous un homme qui exerce du
contrôle curitif et que vous avez senti
ça fait ah non mais attendez après c'est
ça alors moi j'ai assez confianceile on
cette dirait je vais en service public
de l'audiovisuel et je trouve que France
Télévision fait des produit des
téléfilms qui sont absolument
remarquables pour
populariser tout tout les féminicides
les viols comme on les violences les
violences sexuelles tout ça donc il faut
y a une il y a il y a un film notamment
une série qui s'appelle Sambre ah la
série Sambre c'est absolument
remarquable sur comment la police
accueillait les les victimes de viol il
y a 40 ans 35 ans mais on a besoin d'
d'en parler et puis à un moment donné on
qu'on se demande nous on est on est des
êtres humains comment on se comporte
avec les autres êtres humains quel est
notre devoir dans la vie par rapport aux
autres il faut il faut former les gens
par le BIA des des les grands médias et
puis après il faut un peu de courage
dans la vie voilà on peut pas faire
fonctionner une société en comptant
uniquement sur les institutions
publiques sur la justice sur la police
quel est notre courage propre à chacun
d'entre nous de décrocher notre
téléphone d'appeler cette femme de
d'aller d'aller voir des gens qui la
connaissent de dire je crois qu'il y a
un problème en fait autrefois quand un M
quand des femmes étaient frapp quand t
femmes étaient frappées à la maison les
gens se disaient ça nous regarde pas
c'est derrière la porte maintenant ils
appellent la police ça a quand même des
choses qu' on changé et ben il faut
aller plus loin là-dedans c'està dire
qu'il faut aussi prendre nos
responsabilités à l'égard des victimes
et savoir repérer les signaux faibles
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat ici en plateau et
et en duplexe je vous dis à bientôt sur
sur Public Sénat votre prochain
rendez-vous sur notre antenne de la
matinale Orian Mons reçoit Hervé
Marseille le président du groupe Union
centriste ici au Sénat bonne
[Musique]
soirée